la parole est à monsieur Éric
cotti
merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur le Président vous
venez par des mots
empreint d'émotion ce dont je vous
remercie de rendre hommage aux victimes
de cet attentat qui a frappé la ville de
Nice ma ville qui a frappé au cœur notre
pays qui a frappé l'humanité toute
entière puisque c'est à l'humanité c'est
à toute forme d'humanité que cette
barbarie islamiste a voulu une nouvelle
fois s'attaquer je veux à mon tour
exprimer mes
sentiments d'émotion et de
reconnaissance d'émotion bien entendu à
l'égard des familles des victimes
nombreuses vous avez appeler ce terrible
ce terrifiant bilan et en même temps
exprimer ma reconnaissance à tous ceux
qui ont participé à cette formidable
chaîne des secours aux policiers de la
police nationale qui ont intercepté ce
camion avec un courage extraordinaire et
auquel il faut rendre hommage aux
policiers municipaux à toute la chaîne
des secours
mais Monsieur le Premier Ministre cet
attentat ne doit pas nous laisser sans
réponse notre devoir notre
responsabilité cèg
et de tenir compte de ces 240 morts qui
ont frappé la France depuis le Batel
clan vous avez trouvé les mots pour
définir ce phénomène oui la France est
un état de guerre mais vous n'avez pas
trouvé Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
réponse pour
apporter une réponse claire précise
efficace à l'angoiss des Français à la
montée de ce terrorisme alors
aujourd'hui monsieur le Premier ministre
je vous le dis nous vous demandons il
faut changer de stratégie nous sommes en
guerre utilisons les armes de la guerre
parce que si nous ne combattons pas avec
ces armes de la guerre alors ces
terroristes abattront notre démocratie
merci Monsieur la parole est à Monsieur
le Premier Ministre manuel
Vals monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les les députés nous avons
hier c'est vrai jusqu'à tôt ce matin
d'ailleurs longuement discuté de la
prorongation de l'état d'urgence et à
travers ces débats nous avons évoqué
beaucoup de sujets qui viennent d'être
traités à travers vos questions bien sûr
d'abord nos pensées vont vers les
victimes les morts
84 les blessés ceux qui luttent encore
aujourd'hui pour la vie
les blessés handicapés à vie handicapés
pour toujours ceux qui garderont à tout
jamais dans leur chair et dans leur
esprit ces moments atroces je ve aussi
avoir une pensée avec vous dans ces
momentsl pour toutes les victimes des
attentats de ces derniers mois qui
revivent à travers le drame atroce de
Nice ce qu'ils ont pu vivre en janvier
ou en novembre 2015 tous évidemment et
d'ailleurs cela change totalement de
nature le travail d'aide aux victimes
qui devra être le nôtre parce que nous
comptons aujourd'hui des centaines des
milliers de personnes à travers les
familles les proches concernés par ces
attentats c'est quelque chose
malheureusement de totalement inédit
pour notre pays en tout cas depuis euh
ces dernières décennies et donc c'est
vers eux qu'évidemment nous devons nous
tourner bien sûr notre responsabilité
c'est de protéger les Français ils sont
inquiets ils ont peur ils l'expriment et
ils l'ont exprimé partout dignement bien
sûr à travers la minute de silence lundi
et ces moments sont importants à chaque
fois parce qu'il est essentiel que la
nation puisse se retrouver ils l'ont
fait également à Nice et merci de vos
mots monsieur redissal mais je ne
confonds pas ce qui était l'attitude
immense
majorité de cette foule qui se
recueillait qui chantait la Marseillaise
avec ses sifflets et puis de toute façon
il nous appartient à nous ceux qui
gouvernent mais ceux aussi qui
représentent la nation d'endosser et de
porter avec responsabilité lucidité
humilité le poids car c'est un poids
c'est une char
pour chacun d'entre nous j'entends
parfaitement l'exigence des Français et
j'entends aussi l'exigeence de
l'Assemblée nationale comme celle du
Sénat nous aurons l'occasion dans le
débat qui commencera à 17h sur la
prongation de l'état d'urgence de
revenir aussi sur ces questions hier
soir vous l'avez évoqué
monsieurti pour vous comme pour rudal
j'ai évidemment une pensée toute
particulière vous êtes élu de cette
ville Nice de que Claude Bartelone a
décrit avec des mots qui viennent du
cœur d'un
méditerranéen
mais je comprends et tout à fait cette
exigence et notamment la question sur la
la stratégie j'aiété l'un des premiers
c'est aussi mon rôle comme chef du
gouvernement ou avant comme ministre de
l'Intérieur à détecter à me rendre
compte de ce que représente présenter
comme menace dès l'été 2012 les
premières filières sirro irakiennes
est-ce que la cela pouvait représenter
comme menace venant de l'extérieur mais
aussi de l'intérieur et j'avais évoqué
je le répète ici au Sénat d'abord et
ensuite à l'Assemblée en présentant la
première loi antiterroriste qui tirait
les leçons essentiellement des crimes de
Toulouse et de monteoban mais aussi de
la première commission d'enquête sur ce
qui s'était passé en mars 2012 travail
mené par l'Assemblée nationale sous la
haette des députés urvoise et verchè et
j'avais évoqué d'ailleurs un ennemi
intérieur ça m'avait été parfois
reproché mais je voulais qualifier ce
que nous étions en train de connaître
c'est-à-dire les risques d'une véritable
guerre intérieure évidemment sauf à
l'extérieur regardez le beau
documentaire de Bernard Henri levvy
perche Merga sur ce qu'est une guerre au
Kurdistan à la frontière de Mossou
regardonsle parce que c'est à travers ce
type de documentaire o évidemment du
travail des journalistes qu'on voit ce
qu'est la réalité de cette guerre mais
en France les choses sont évidemment
très différentes c'est très différent
mais c'est une guerre c'est une guerre
qui n'a rien à voir avec ce que nous
avons connu au 20e siècle mais c'est une
guerre qui nous est menée chacun l'a dit
avec ses mots et c'est pour cela que
nous avons pris en responsabilité tous
les moyens
tous les moyens les lois qui par
ailleurs ont été voté par une immense
majorité des parlementaires les deux
lois antiterroristes celles que j'ai
portter celle que Bernard casazneuve
apporté les deux lois sur le
renseignement et je l'ai évoqué hier ça
faisait 30 ans que nous n'avions pas une
nouvelle loi sur le renseignement la
précédente avait été portée par Michel
Rocard et par edit cresson en
1991 et c'est lois es sont nécessaires
c'est pas un seul outil parce que nous
voyons bien que c'est à la fois le
traitement humain le travail de la
police et de la la gendarmerie du
renseignement le travail sur les réseaux
sociaux sur Internet la mobilisation de
la société qui doivent être engagé pour
lutter contre le terrorisme la nouvelle
loi de procédure pénale annoncée
confortée par le Président de la
République lors de son discours à
Versailles les amendements qui ont été
pris venant de tous les groupes de la
majorité comme de l'opposition de
l'Assemblée comme du Sénat nous
permettre d'avoir un arsenal que je
crois à la mesure du défi qui nous est
posé alors bien
sûr il faut en permanence s'adapter
parce que l'ennemi l'adversaire lui
s'adapte en permanence il s'adapte en
permanence d'ailleurs nous voyons bien
que nous faisons face au moins au moins
à deux mode opératoire
l'organisation de groupes depuis la
Syrie ou l'Irak coordonné en Belgique ou
en France pour ce qui concerne les
derniers attentas avec des
parcours avec des individus au parcours
criminel délinquant AG guuéri souvent au
manimement des armes de guerre et qui
ont commis ces attentats et d'ailleurs
grâce à nos services 16 projets
d'attentat ont été déjoués don celui du
groupe cricket je l'ai évoqué en mars
dernier et qui s'apprêtait à commettre
des attentats particulièrement
meurtriers mais nous avons un autre mode
opératoire au moins qui est celui que
nous avons vu à Nice qui plus est là
cette fois-ci avec un individu
radicalisé sans doute en très peu de
temps inconnu des services pas fichier s
connu uniquement défavorablement par les
services de police pour les raisons qui
ont été évoquées ou par les services
sociaux du conseil départemental des
Alpes Maritime et donc face à cela nous
devons nous adapter je pense que nous
avons les outils en matière de police de
gendarmerie de renseignement et encore
une fois ceci peut être amélioré nous
l'avons déjà amélioré c'est c'est sousm
responsabilité comme ministre de
l'Intérieur que nous avons fait la
réforme de la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure et avec un vrai
sujet nous avons évoqué hier la
disparition des renseignements généraux
mais moi je crois vraiment comme le
ministre de l'Intérieur que nous devons
nous appuyer sur la police et sur la
gendarmerie pour ce renseignement de
proximité pour recueillir le maximum
d'information en lien bien sûr avec les
travailleurs sociaux avec les services
sociaux et le travail qui est mené par
le gouvernement par les ministres
Marisol Touren ou laurenceignol va dans
ce sens puisque il s'agit de mobiliser
tous les services sociaux avec souvent
des cultures qui sont très différentes
par rapport au travail bien sûr de la
police de la gendarmerie ou de la
justice et nous pensons que police
gendarmerie justice ont aujourd'hui ces
moyens mais là encore faut être ouvert
attentif tout ce qui peut nous permettre
en efficacité de mieux lutter contre le
terrorisme sans jamais sortir de l'ordre
constitutionnel et de l'État de droit le
gouvernement il sera pleinement attentif
enfin
bien évidemment j'aurai l'occasion tout
à l'heure de répondre à une question sur
les opérations extérieures c'est
évidemment tout à fait essentiel puisque
la guerre se joue au moins à court et à
moyen terme en Irak en Syrie sans doute
en Libye mais pas seulement la guerre
elle sera très longue très longue sur
notre sol et quand je dis quand j'ai dit
qu'il y aurait d'autres
attentats d'autres victimes innocentes
même si mal Bouti avait tout à fait
raison hier de dire dans
que nous faisons tout pour les empêcher
et que nous gagnerons bien sûr cette
guerre c'est pas par fatalisme mais
c'est parce que nous devons cette vérité
au français et si tout l'arsenal qui
était proposé hier soir ou par d'autres
en dehors de cette enceinte était adopté
et mise en œuvre et qu'il y aurait des
attentats quel est le nouveau pas que
nous devrions à ce moment-là franchir
nous voyons bien la difficulté regardez
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis patriote
acte peine de mort en Floride moyens
exceptionnels qui ont été mis en œuvre
est-ce que le drame d'Orlando a pu être
évité ça veut bien dire que c'est d'une
très grande complexité et que le
terrorisme de daesh son idéologie les
kits qu'il fournit à ces terroristes à
ces individus quel que soit le
qualificatif à ces terroristes à ces
meurtriers et d'une très grande
efficacité malheureusement et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut se mobiliser et Madame la
Députée vous avez tout à fait raison de
dire la la la seule réponse dite
sécuritaire est évidemment indispensable
comme la réponse judiciaire avec
l'aggravation des peines mais on voit
bien que c'est toute la mobilisation de
la société qui est nécessaire j'y
reviendrai aussi tout à l'heure enfin
pardon monsieur le Président mais je
voudraisêtre précis sur un sujet et je
veux répondre à rudissal de la manière
la plus précise et avec la précision
chère au ministre de l'Intérieur
concernant les événements de Nice parce
que je pense qu'il faut donner tous ces
élé
ici à l'Assemblée nationale comme l'a
rappelé le préfet des Alpes Maritimes
l'organisation du feu d'artifice
monsieur le député vous le savez du 14
juillet avait été précédé de deux
réunions qui associaient la ville et la
préfecture ainsi que deux autres
réunions les premiers et 12 juillet
entre la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique et la police
municipale police municipale que je
connais bien je suis souvent aller à
Nice nous avons souvent dit d'ailleurs
avec Monsieur estroszi et cioti que les
deux polices municipales les plus
efficaces qui pouvaient exister étaient
celle de Nice cell d'evri évidemment
beaucoup moins nombreus que celle de la
ville de niete donc je connais bien
cette efficacité et je connais bien
aussi la vidéo surveillance mais nous
savons tous que ça ne suffit pas lors de
la première réunion qui s'est déroulé le
28 juin à 15h la préfecture avait appelé
l'attention de la ville sur la nécessité
de mieux sécuriser l'environnement de la
manifestation lors de la seconde réunion
qui s'est déroulée le 7 juillet à 15h un
accord avait été trouvé pour mettre en
place un contrôle aléatoire des accès
comme pour le carnaval de Nice autres
grandes manifestation un arrêté du 11
juillet signé par le directeur général
adjoint de la ville le directeur général
adjoint en charge de la sécurité de la
proximitéés et des quartiers réglementa
la circulation sur la Promenade des
Anglais et ses abords car c'est une
responsabilité du maire de la police
municipale ce dispositif a été concerté
consenti est validé par le maire de Nice
sinon cela aurait signifié que la
collectivité locale organisatrice du feu
l'artifice c'est pas l'état qui organise
des feux d'artifice dans ce pays aurait
accepté l'organisation d'un événement
sans souscrire au dispositif de sécurité
qui peut l'imaginer un seul instant et
pour cause le ministre de l'Intérieur a
reconstitué la liste de tous les
policiers nationaux qui étaient sur le
terrain à partir des mains courantes
attestant de leur engagement ils étaient
85 à 19h 89 à 20h 92 à 21h 64 entre 22h
et 23h et nous tenons ce tableau
récapitulatif des présences à la
disposition de la justice en tout et
pour tout 185 policiers nationaux et 20
militaires de l'opération sentinelle
étaient mobilisés à Nice dans le cadre
des festivité du 14 juillet et par
ailleurs les policiers municipaux
étaient en périphérie de l'événement en
charge notamment de la circulation et
c'est d'ailleurs cela a été rappelé par
tous le courage des fonctionnaires de
police présents qui a permis de stopper
le terroriste avant qu'il ne tue
davantage et ce travail avait évidemment
été nourri par l'expérience de la
préparation de l'euro puisque cinq
exercices antiterroristes majeurs
avaient été organisés à Nice voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés moi je
suis convaincu que le pays a besoin de
vérité a besoin de tout savoir mais nous
devons nous qui exerçons les
responsabilités vous qui êtes
parlementaire vous qui avez exercé les
responsabilités vous qui souhaitez à
nouveau exercer des responsabilités nous
avons un devoir de vérité et d'exigence
vis-à-vis de nos compatriotes ça sera un
combat long difficile il y aura encore
malheureusement des victimes mais ce
combat nous le gagnerons au Levant et en
France parce que c'est la France qui a
été attaqué parce que c'est les pays des
droits de l'homme parce que c'est le
pays de la lacité parce que c'est un
pays qui prend ses responsabilités au
Levant comme au Sahel parce que c'est un
pays qui compte des millions de
compatriotes et de concitoyens musulmans
et que le terrorisme s'attaque à notre
société pour la diviser et nous
vaincrons et nous vaincrons d'autant
plus que nous serons unis et solidaires
face au terrorisme pour le
vaincre